pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche
bonjour à toutes les épis curieuse et
tous les épées curieux aujourd'hui c'est
mercredi le mercredi c'est un petit peu
notre cour de récréation puisque je
réponds à vos questions on commence par
cédric boucher sur youtube dit jamie est
ce que tu penses pouvoir traiter
certaines expressions québécoises dans
tes vidéos
pourquoi on dit eh bien c'est vrai que
c'est une excellente idée
j'adorerais cet exercice alors des
expressions québécoises mais pas
uniquement des expressions francophones
quelle que soit leur origine par
conséquent et bien n'hésitez pas à
m'envoyer ses expressions en commentaire
de cette vidéo et puis si vous avez
aussi l'explication est bien donnée là
moi je serais pour qu'ils voient source
comme on dit au québec une question de
choses 951 sur twitter dit jamie
survivre et oms une météorite de la même
taille que celle qui a tué les
dinosaures s'abattait sur terre alors
pour toutes celles et ceux qui ont peur
que le ciel leur tombe sur la tête
sachez que j'ai fait une petite vidéo
sur ce sujet pendant le premier
confinement pour la retrouver sur
youtube elle a été postée à la fin avril
2020 gelé réalisé au moment du passage
de l'astéroïde 1998 au r2 pour mémoire
l'astéroïde qui s'est abattue sur terre
il ya 65 millions d'années qui a
provoqué la disparition des dinosaures
mesurait entre 10 et 12 km s'il a eu un
tel effet c'est aussi parce qu'il est
tombé un endroit très particulier là où
il y avait des réserves de pétrole
naturel ce qui a amplifié les effets de
la collision par conséquent si un
astéroïde de la même taille retombé sur
terre aujourd'hui mais à un autre
endroit évidemment et provoquerait
d'importants dégâts mais pas sûr qu'ils
fassent disparaître autant d'espèces que
celui qui est tombé sur terre il ya 65
millions d'années
tout cas je l'espère parce que je n'ai
pas envie de terminer comme les
dinosaures dit jamais fais tu de la
musique c'est une question d'illusions
sur youtube et bien malheureusement non
je ne fais pas de musique mais je ne
désespère pas je rêve de jouer un jour
de la clarinette
c'est pas du pipeau une question de paul
sur twitter dit jeanne ici un
hélicoptère utilisé un moteur
entièrement électrique est ce qu il
ferait encore beaucoup de bruit alors il
ferait sûrement moins de bruit mais il
ne serait pas totalement silencieux en
effet le frottement de l'air sur les
pales des pales qui tourne très vite
générerait également du bruit c'est pas
un hasard si on éloigne les éoliennes
des habitations qui tourne moins vite
que les pales d'un hélicoptère entendons
nous bien dit jamie pourrais-tu
participer à notre exposé alors vous
êtes très nombreux à me faire ce genre
de demande beaucoup trop nombreux même
si je répondais à toutes vos demandes et
bien je n'aurai plus le temps de faire
autre chose le temps de répondre à cette
faq de tourner des vidéos avec la petite
caméra d'écrire des livres de fabriquer
des mondes de jamie en revanche sachez
que la plupart des thèmes sur lesquels
vous travaillez ont été abordés dans
différentes émissions dans l'est c'est
pas sorcier avec fred et sabine dans
l'incroyable expérience dans le monde de
jamie dans les vidéos qui sont
disponibles sur ma chaîne youtube
et puis enfin je vais vous confier
quelque chose vous savez j'aime beaucoup
expliqué mais j'aime surtout de poser
des questions est allé chercher des
réponses
et quand on trouve la réponse dans un
livre sur un site internet ou auprès
d'un expert et bien là on éprouve une
grande joie
faites l'essai et vous m'en direz des
nouvelles
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus merci les
épis curieux pour les plus gourmands
en voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche